here in the u.s coronavirus cases
continue to spike across the country as
the delta variant fuels new infections
the nation saw a 14 percent jump in the
number of covet 19 cases caused by the
highly contagious strain on tuesday
alone more than 1 000 people died
reuters calculated that at 42 fatalities
per hour michael george joins us now
with the latest michael good morning
elaine good morning the covet infection
rate is rising in nearly every state
hospitals especially in the south are
being pushed to the brink as icu's are
swamped with mostly unvaccinated
patients
intensive care units are in shorter and
shorter supply this one in tennessee was
converted from a cardiac unit and a new
tented field hospital was built
alongside the university of mississippi
in jackson
the cost of treating so many seriously
ill patients is high 42 thousand dollars
per patient last year according to a
recent review health professionals more
and more aren't holding back on their
frustrations today when we need to be
trusted more than
ever people are doubting us and we need
to trust the science behind
the vaccine
and utilize the only defense that we
have while the number of vaccinations
has increased more than a million on
thursday alone they aren't going up fast
enough in many places the situation in
kansas is cause for real concern nearly
all the people admitted to our icu's
with covet-related issues are
unvaccinated
an illinois police department is shut
down after every officer tested positive
when 23 faculty members called out sick
a tennessee school called a snow day
jamisha dowell mother of two objects if
we're using the inclement weather days
how is it going to affect you know when
we really need them
how is one closed day going to suffice
for the 14 day foreign team in texas a
state court sided with one county's
decision to require masks for students
after the governor took a no mask stand
it gives us
an opportunity to do the right thing the
right thing
when it comes to practicing
protecting us our citizens our families
and our most vulnerable our children
governor laura kelly is asking school
boards to take action fast i urge every
school board across kansas that hasn't
already to implement mask requirements
in their schools
until the vaccine is approved for
children under 12
mass can prevent students from
quarantine from getting very sick and
dying from cobit 19.
and the debate over masks could end up
being fought in the courtroom the
department of education put eight states
on notice for blocking school mass
mandates warning they could face legal
action or cuts in federal funding
michelle
okay thank you michael